bueno para quienes trabajamos con el
diálogo y quienes creemos que el diálogo
es un camino para la construcción de
sociedades más justas la realidad nos
pone con mucha frecuencia una pregunta
incómoda que es necesitamos llegar hasta
un estallido social con confrontación y
con violencia para tomarnos en serio el
problema de la desigualdad y el tema de
la pobreza
en otras palabras la pregunta es es
necesaria la violencia para lograr una
sociedad más justa
yo creo que no verdad pero vale la pena
hacerse la pregunta
y cuando se dan estallidos que ponen en
jaque la estabilidad institucional de
nuestros países
es común que la primera explicación sea
bueno es que con esta desigualdad como
no explicar un estallido y es verdad en
américa latina somos conocidos por ser
la región más desigual del mundo 20 por
ciento de la población más rica se queda
con el 55 por ciento de los ingresos el
3 por ciento más rico tiene el 20% de
los ingresos además una de cada 4
personas vive en la pobreza una de cada
3 personas vive en situación de
vulnerabilidad que es esa franja delgada
e inestable entre la pobreza y la clase
media
pero aún así es probable que la
desigualdad y la pobreza no expliquen un
estallido hay gente que dice que en
realidad un estallido además necesita
una frustración de expectativas es decir
si ustedes ven
que entre el año 2003 y el 2013 producto
de precios muy altos de las materias
primas que exportamos nuestros países en
la región vivieron un crecimiento
sostenido y ese crecimiento sostenido
produjo una reducción progresiva de la
desigualdad y un aumento de la clase
media y mucha gente empezó a sentir que
tenía al alcance de la mano la
posibilidad de una vida mejor y cuando
las economías se desaceleran en el 2013
esa expectativa se frustra ahora a mi
modo de ver ninguna de las dos cosas por
si solas o en conjunto explican un
estallido para mí un estallido se da
cuando la mayoría de la población no
confía en que su clase dirigencial
económica y política tiene a la
población y sobre todo a los más
vulnerables en el centro de sus
prioridades
porque cuando existe esa confianza en
los líderes económicos y políticos la
sociedad está dispuesta a ser un
sacrificio está dispuesta a esperar está
dispuesta a entender que quizás el
contexto internacional no ayude o
incluso a perdonar algún error de sus
dirigentes
pero yo creo que en américa latina' la
confianza en los líderes económicos y
políticos está rota y creo que está rota
principalmente porque las élites han
perdido la capacidad de conectarse con
la realidad que vive la mayor parte de
la población
la serie es en general son endogámicas
viven en círculos muy cerrados las
crisis económicas no afectan sus
bolsillos no es de extrañar que tengan
anestesiada la capacidad de ponerse en
el lugar del otro la capacidad de sentir
lo que el otro siente y eso a la mayor
parte de la población la exaspera
por eso y yo creo que eso explica un
estallido social y por eso
cuando se toma una medida para alentar
la inversión como por ejemplo reducir
algún impuesto al sector privado con la
expectativa de que el sector privado
pueda generar riqueza y el estado la
pueda redistribuir esa medida es vista
como una medida que beneficia a los
ricos
pero no se ve como una medida que
beneficie al resto de la población y
muchas veces tenemos manifestaciones y
resistencias frente a eso se postula
entonces que en realidad no es el estado
el que tiene que tener un rol mucho más
protagónico en decidir cómo se genera
riqueza y cómo se reparte la riqueza y a
veces el rol del estadio del estado
genera un alivio de corto plazo pero es
difícil sostenerlo en el tiempo
entonces nuestros países van en zigzag
entre estas propuestas que proponen un
estado protagónico y estas propuestas
que ponen al sector privado en el centro
de la generación de riqueza y como me
decía un hombre de campo en argentina
vamos como esa gente que no sabe
conducir en los caminos de ripio los de
ripio son esos de piedra suelta y tierra
que apenas se le desacomodó a la
camioneta un poco corrigen bruscamente
hacia la izquierda y luego tienen que
corregir bruscamente a la derecha y
nuevamente bruscamente a la izquierda
iván con el acelerador apretado
rapidísimo pero no avanzan y además cada
tanto hay que ir con un tractor a
sacarlos de la zanja en la que cayeron
entonces como arreglamos esto
mucha gente y creo que todos estamos de
acuerdo en que la riqueza está mal
distribuida pero todos repiten nos
repetimos que el camino es la
redistribución ahora la redistribución
de la riqueza es un proceso costoso es
un proceso complejo y muy conflictivo
implica sacarle algunos para darles a
otros
y
si uno piensa por ejemplo en cualquier
sector de la economía que aprovecha los
recursos naturales
y generan riqueza en un determinado del
territorio parte de esa riqueza va a
parar al gobierno central el gobernante
de turno decide que esa riqueza va a ir
a ciertas personas decide cómo va a
suceder eso cuánto de esa riqueza se va
a repartir y cuándo y quizás con suerte
algo de esa riqueza regrese al mismo
territorio de dónde salió
y yo me pregunto no será mejor compartir
la riqueza allí donde se genera en lugar
de apostar tanto por la redistribución
y no será que podemos reconectar a las
élites con la población más vulnerable
si se pueden asociar las élites
económicas y las comunidades más
vulnerables en la generación de riqueza
compartir la riqueza allí donde se
genera en el lugar que se genera y en el
mismo momento en que se genera
y esto
yo creo que se puede poner en práctica o
se puede explorar mucho en el campo de
las energías renovables ustedes saben
que nuestros países han impulsado una
transición energética hacia energías más
limpias y tratar de abandonar
progresivamente los combustibles fósiles
los proyectos eólicos solares o pequeñas
hidroeléctricas en general tienen pocos
impactos ambientales y sin embargo
crecientemente vamos a escuchando
noticias de comunidades que los resisten
que los enfrentan que queman maquinarias
y luego y represión policial y hay
muertos por 10 megawatts por 5 megawatts
y
las comunidades que hacen esto que
oponen se oponen a estos proyectos son
etiquetadas como enemigas del progreso a
mí me ha tocado ser mediador en algunos
de estos casos de conflicto y cuando uno
le pregunta a la comunidad por qué se
oponen a un proyecto que tiene tan pocos
impactos ambientales la respuesta no es
muy difícil de entender
dicen llevamos décadas de abandono del
estado nuestros jóvenes tienen que
emigrar a vivir en la periferia de las
ciudades para poder tener un trabajo
nos prometieron la riqueza del petróleo
y de la minería y quedó todo en una
promesa vimos cómo salió mucha riqueza
de nuestro territorio y quedamos igual o
peor
ahora vienen con un proyecto de energía
renovable porque tendría que ser
distinto para nosotros nos vienen con un
proyecto que ya está diseñado y nos
dicen que nos consultan nos preguntan si
nos parece bien que los camiones lleguen
por este camino o por este otro pero
nadie nos pregunta si nos parece bien el
proyecto
nos proponen un paquete de beneficios
sociales que son las mismas cosas que le
venimos exigiendo al estado hace décadas
y que son nuestro derecho sin embargo
nos terminamos preguntando si no tenemos
que aceptar esta alternativa porque no
tenemos otra opción entonces hay
comunidades que ante la falta de
alternativas deciden aceptar un proyecto
en su territorio y entrar en una
negociación del precio de la paz decir
cuánto te puedo sacar para que vos hagas
tu proyecto yo te dejo tranquilo
y hay otras comunidades que abiertamente
van por el lado de la confrontación
ahora cuando uno le pregunta a los
dirigentes de las comunidades y no me
refiero a los activistas políticos me
refiero a los líderes de las comunidades
como debería ser un proyecto para que
ustedes lo consideren justo y respetuoso
la respuesta también es fácil de
entender dicen a mí me gustaría que nos
consideren desde el principio y que nos
inviten a participar como socios es
decir queremos ser parte del negocio
y cuando uno transmite esto al sector
privado uno escucha bueno pero son
comunidades que tienen economía de
subsistencia que pueden invertir para
ser socios en un proyecto que requiere
millones de dólares o como vamos a hacer
para entendernos si nos peleamos entre
socios que fuimos a los mismos colegios
o universidades
y las preguntas son válidas pero una
cosa que he aprendido es que el sector
privado tiene una enorme habilidad para
resolver problemas y desafíos
pero resuelve los desafíos que quieres
resolver
y en canadá el sector privado del día ha
encontrado respuestas a estas preguntas
en conjunto con las comunidades
indígenas de canadá han venido
desarrollando una serie de proyectos
maravillosos por ejemplo jugó antes de
eso hay por lo menos 100 proyectos de
energía renovable en canadá donde las
comunidades tienen una participación
accionaria
la ontario power generation company
tiene con la comunidad del axel un
proyecto de 12 megavatios un proyecto
hidroeléctrico donde la comunidad tiene
el 25 por ciento del capital accionario
y desde el 2009 todos los años reciben
un cheque con sus dividendos
también tienen un proyecto muchísimo más
grande hidroeléctrico de 440 megawatts
con la comunidad de mus click que tiene
25 por ciento también del capital
accionario y además tienen proyectos
solares de energía solar con otras seis
comunidades que se unieron para hacer
una única empresa y participar en este
proyecto y no es esta empresa solamente
energex glover train your balls
brooksfield sancor todas estas que son
líderes en su sector todas tienen
acuerdos de participación accionaria con
las comunidades indígenas y en ningún
caso le regalaron a las comunidades su
participación
las comunidades hicieron su aporte en
algunos casos económicos en otros casos
fueron aportes de usufructo de la tierra
y además el estado en ontario por
ejemplo a palanca e incentiva este tipo
de asociaciones por ejemplo dar una
garantía para los préstamos que toman
las empresas que tienen participación
accionaria indígena
o en el caso de british columbia han
creado un fondo para que las comunidades
puedan invertir de manera temprana en el
desarrollo de proyectos de este tipo
ahora hay mucho para aprender de canadá
mucho más pero hay una cosa que a mí me
quedó de conversar con un alto ejecutivo
de ipys y de esta empresa y me dijo
espero que ustedes en américa latina no
tengan que transitar el camino largo
tortuoso de conflicto y confrontación
que nosotros transitamos para darnos
cuenta de que había otra manera de hacer
las cosas y de manera más justa
así que absolutamente entusiasmados con
todo lo que aprendimos de canadá
decidimos dedicarnos a hacer esto en
américa latina con un conjunto de
colegas y en la patagonia argentina con
la comunidad de mí ya que es una
comunidad mapuche que vive en el norte
de la patagonia empezamos a desarrollar
juntos un proyecto eólico nos acercamos
a la comunidad y les dijimos miren
ustedes tienen buen viento tienen dos
líneas de transmisión que atraviesan su
territorio tienen una vía que atraviesa
el territorio también aquí se podría
hacer un proyecto eólico pero les
proponemos que lo vamos a hacer
solamente si ustedes quieren ser
nuestros socios
nos abrieron los ojos como platos y la
sensación era esto está demasiado bien
tiene que tener una trampa
y nos hicieron varias preguntas hasta
que al final nos preguntaron bueno pero
qué ponemos nosotros y nosotros creamos
chivos que podemos invertir en un
proyecto así y nuestra propuesta es dos
cosas primero la comunidad puede aportar
el usufructo de su tierra número 1 y
número 2 la comunidad puede hacer co
desarrolladora de los proyectos con
nosotros qué implica esto implica ir a
ver a los inversores ir a ver a los
bancos e ir a ver al estado y
preguntarle en qué estado está el
proceso de aprobación de nuestro estudio
de impacto ambiental ir a ver a los
potenciales compradores de la energía
con nosotros y créanme que una comunidad
participe en estas actividades le agrega
valor al proyecto no se lo resta
esto lo hemos visto de manera muy
concreta en particular la comunidad ha
sido la que ha conseguido un potencial
comprador de la energía para nosotros
así que bueno hemos recorrido con esta
comunidad un largo camino y nos queda
todavía muchísimo y podemos fracasar
pero quizás el indicador más bonito de
que estamos construyendo una relación de
socios es que la comunidad nos invitó a
participar con ellos en dos proyectos
más un proyecto de minería no metálica
de baja escala ni un proyecto de
construcción de un parador de camiones y
les hemos dicho que si íbamos a trabajar
juntos en los tres proyectos
mucha gente nos ha dicho bueno esto
suena muy bien pero no puede pasar que
inunden una comunidad con recursos que
luego no pueden administrar y manejar
y si es un riesgo pero también
aprendiendo de los canadienses las
comunidades que establecieron fondos de
fideicomiso para administrar sus
dividendos son las que mejor están hoy
sus asambleas le dieron a estos
fideicomisos instrucciones claras de qué
hacer con los recursos que obtienen
y lo bonito de esto es que las preguntas
ya empiezan a hacer sobre el riesgo del
éxito de esta forma de trabajar y no ya
sobre su viabilidad
también nos han dicho bueno pero esto
suena muy boutique con una cosa que uno
solamente puede hacer con una comunidad
que tiene propiedad comunitaria de la
tierra y no es así
en nepal
construyen centrales hidroeléctricas
en su primer momento tuvieron mucha
oposición de las comunidades y en
conversación con las comunidades
llegaron nuevamente a la conclusión de
que las comunidades querían ser parte
del negocio y la forma que encontraron
fue que todas las personas que viven en
el área de influencia de un proyecto
tienen el derecho a comprar acciones en
ese proyecto y si hace una oferta
pública local de acciones hasta un 10%
del capital accionario y eso hoy por hoy
aunque no lo crean en nepal es un
derecho constitucional está en la
constitución de nepal
y además esto podríamos hacerlo en todo
tipo de empresa en realidad con los
trabajadores de hecho se hace con los
trabajadores darle la opción a los
trabajadores de comprar hasta cierto
porcentaje del capital accionario
y el estado en américa latina' que puede
hacer bueno ahí sí que puede reducir
impuestos para las empresas que decidan
compartir la riqueza en la fuente es una
manera de premiar no pueden garantizar
préstamos tomados por este tipo de
empresas o pueden hacer como en
sudáfrica que en las licitaciones para
comprar energía premian con un mayor
puntaje a aquellas empresas que
comparten la riqueza en la fuente
entonces si tomamos conciencia del poder
que tiene esta idea de compartir la
riqueza en la fuente y si nos ponemos de
acuerdo entre el sector público el
sector privado y sectores sociales para
implementarlo a gran escala yo estoy
seguro que podemos crecer reducir la
pobreza y dejar de ser la región más
desigual del planeta
si lo hacemos vamos a haber enderezado
el rumbo de nuestra camioneta no vamos a
necesitar ningún tractor que nos venga a
sacar de ninguna zanja y la respuesta a
la pregunta inicial es no no necesitamos
ningún estallido violento para construir
una sociedad más justa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]